the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program
and do not necessarily reflect the views
and opinions of 8 news now or next our
media group
we're proud that we're making an
investment in our kids
on politics now the legislative session
is over we look at the state's biggest
boost to education funding
and the new mining tax deal obviously
what we are trying to do is make sure
that it is as easy as possible for
people to get registered to vote
nevada expands mail-in voting and tries
to leap frog to the front of the primary
line
we'll break down all the new election
laws and rules plus nevada getting legal
pot lounges
just how soon tourists will have a place
to smoke their marijuana
from 8 news now this is politics now
i moved at the senate of the 81st
session
of the senate of the legislature of the
state of nevada adjourn
sinai die
[Applause]
there it is after 120 days and a last
minute flurry of votes the 2021
legislative session is over
we thank you for joining us here on
politics now i'm john langler now the
itunes david charns the only local tv
reporter here from southern nevada
to go up to carson city for the end of
the session and david you're here to
kind of sort it all out there's a lot
that happened here
it was quite the end and the run up to
midnight there and with control
of both houses democrats were able to
really get large
chunks of their agenda passed that means
mail-in voting that public health
insurance option
and marijuana lounges well all is calm
now outside of the nevada legislature
but
in true nevada style lawmakers went up
right until that deadline first session
of the nevada legislature is adjourned
minutes before midnight tuesday the
senate and assembly called an end to
their four-month session
one that brought changes to elections
policing and taxes
we help the small businesses we help the
community we help
students we put money towards education
it was never
happened before that money after
lawmakers scrambled to reach a deal
on taxing the mining industry the
bipartisan plan is expected to bring
about 80 million dollars into education
every year mining had a gun to their
heads don't kid yourself so
i don't really even have a problem with
mining pay a reasonable
additional amount but they've got to be
exceptionally careful nevada will also
move toward voting in primaries instead
of caucuses
assembly speaker jason fryerson says
that proposal
and expanded mail-in voting only makes
the democratic process easier
with added protections for signature
verification and the days ballots can be
accepted
we believe that as a constitutional
right people should have
every option to fully participate now
you allow mail-in ballots to come in
a little later and so it's days almost a
week until you get your election
results and people automatically start
to begin to get suspicious
decriminalizing traffic stops
creating a public health insurance
option and a new structure to regulate
marijuana lounges there's just a lot the
good things that happen
and i'm proud of them we're going to
take the bills one at a time the
governor has 10 days to either
sign a bill veto it or let it become law
without his signature
he tells me what started as a big
unknown with the coronavirus pandemic
has ended with a feeling of hope and
confidence
all right so here are some more details
on that mining tax it's an excise tax
that'll be 0.8 percent for mines that
make
less than 20 million dollars a year
sites that make more than that more than
20 million dollars a year
they get bumped up to 1.1 percent there
are currently 103 mines of all sizes
here in nevada
here's how democrats and republicans
reacted to the measure
nevada when our economy is based on all
gaming
we don't survive and so we have to
diversify our economy we have to do more
with revenue
and we need to have a broader
conversation about revenue this is the
beginning of that conversation this is a
good start
in a statement the chair of the nevada
republican party michael mcdonald said
quote
ab-495 much like any new tax introduced
in nevada is a clear violation of the
party's platform the republican party's
platform
and an unnecessary solution to a problem
brought by the democrats inability to
lead and govern so david
that mining tax it's part of nearly a
billion dollars
extra dollars that went to public
education funding this session
yeah a lot of talk about education this
session and yeah in addition to that
there's actually about a half
billion more dollars added to that going
to that base per student funding
and then yet another 200 million dollars
in federal funding coronavirus stimulus
funding that will
add things like learning loss and work
on child literacy so you can probably
call this the biggest investment
in k-12 education that nevada has made
so far
now there are also two ballot
initiatives that teachers unions
proposed
before the pandemic one was a gaming tax
there was also a sales tax
what was the future for those well there
actually was a separate bill that would
let them
withdraw those two ballot initiatives so
the ccca
is expected to do that so those won't be
on the table
all right well nevada may be the second
state to offer a public option for
health care
by the time this passed ab420 it had
been amended several times
washington state was the first to offer
a public option for health care
nevada's version requires that insurers
that bid to provide coverage for people
under medicaid
must also offer a public option plan
they'll be similar to other plans
offered by the state exchange but with a
five percent markdown
but it's not going to take effect for a
while now they're not going to have to
offer that option until 2026.
also from the legislative session legal
places to smoke
pot the bill creating consumption
lounges has
passed there will be licenses for
existing businesses
and 20 independent ones as well david
this has been an ongoing discussion here
in nevada especially in southern nevada
with all the resort corridors
how long before these pot lounges are
awesome to start opening up well
first of all the governor has to sign it
it's going to take a couple of months
once he does sign it we do expect him to
do that the cannabis compliance board
will
still have to set up all the rules and
regulations on how you're going to get a
license for that so it's going to take a
while before businesses then apply for
them
they have to be approved open up do
they'll do the whole thing
and dance before may not be very soon
john what other maybe a major marijuana
legislation did pass up in carson city
well
the bill to allow curbside pickup that a
lot of folks had wanted during the
pandemic
also passed and that started right away
so you can do that now
the other major one that would have
allowed pop-up tents at events and
festivals though
did not pass and we profiled that issue
on politics now a couple of weeks ago as
well
a lot of marijuana lobbyists up in
carson city by the way this session
well meantime new sweeping clean energy
legislation accelerates a huge
transmission project and puts in more
electric charging stations we're talking
about green link nevada it's a two
billion dollar project that basically
links
the entire state with two transmission
lines every energy envy energy that is
has to finish it by 2029 that's eight
years from now
it requires a plan from nb energy to
spend 100 million dollars on new
electric vehicle charging stations all
across the state
and it also takes the state's renewable
energy portfolio standard which we've
told you about it's that 50 percent by
2030
even further utilities now have to come
up with a plan to see an
80 percent reduction in the 2005
carbon dioxide admission levels by then
nv energy told us
senate bill 448 will transform nevada's
clean energy landscape
create thousands of good paying jobs and
ensure nevada's underserved and
low-income communities benefit from this
energy transformation we'll maybe have
one of these plates the classic car
loophole has been closed
now in order to get one of the plates
which exempts cars from a smog
check people will have to have classic
car insurance
maybe you drive one of those 2011 law
just to find classic cars as any car
that's over a certain age
which is why you've seen so many beat up
ones on the road
with those classic car plates john all
right well let's talk about some bills
that did not pass the legislative
session
we previously told you about a measure
to try and end the death penalty that
failed to pass it's a bill from senate
majority leader nicole cannizzaro it
would have essentially
also made casinos gun-free zones that
also
didn't pass that was pushed by mgm
resorts a law that would have made it
that lat law rather would have made it a
crime to ignore signs on any business
with signs that say no guns allowed
however it had several stipulations
including a warning before staff could
call police
i obviously brought that legislation
because i do think that we have to take
gun violence here in this state
seriously
i definitely believe that we should have
tools to be able to enforce that
we have done that on a number of
different occasions here in the in this
state and certainly while i've been in
this building
with background checks to make sure that
domestic abusers don't have access to
guns
with making sure that our libraries our
government buildings
and other facilities like education
facilities can
ensure the safety of those individuals
there and this is no different from that
so david as this went through the
legislative process there was an unusual
group
of opposition to it a lot of different
people were unopposed
yeah something we don't normally see
there was an opposition from republican
gun
rights groups like the nevada firearms
coalition which we would expect you know
in the in this
this day and age but also progressive
groups like battleborn progress and even
the aclu
even pro-gun control groups like the
giffords group
had objections to this now those
objections were different than what
republicans
objected to but effectively killed this
whole thing if both sides are against it
it's not going to go
too far up in carson city though it did
come pretty close to passing yeah and
it's sort of
we it's different this time usually we
see things close in the assembly or
passed up the assembly this time it
passed the senate
11 to 10 which is more than uh the
majority
um the the republican voted for that but
though it did not make it out of the
assembly all right well another thing
that my i-team colleague vanessa murphy
covered would have created a licensing
commission for midwives this is assembly
bill 387
it required a two-thirds vote because
there were licensing fees for midwives
associated with this
nevada is the only state in the west
that does not require
midwives to be licensed you can go watch
vanessa's story right now on our website
a newsnow.com
so this did pass out the assembly but
then it missed passing in the senate by
just
one vote thirteen to eight and it wasn't
along any part of lines either john
and you mentioned vanessa our own
vanessa murphy covered this issue deeply
nevada now will still be the only state
without the licensing for midwives we
have all those stories stolen
eightnewsnow.com though
interesting story interesting topic for
sure well i did ask governor sisselak if
he had any favorite
bills you know there's so many this is
what he said
there's a lot of them that are favorites
to me i mean the
the mining tax is incredible it's huge
like i said my team works so hard to get
that across the finish line i mean
fixing dieter is big to me it's
important there's so many i mean there's
money that went towards medical school
there's just a lot the
good things that a long legislative
session
is over good coverage up in carson city
hope you enjoyed your first session up
there
next on politics now we do have more
believe it or not on the legislative
session
we're going to dig into the bill making
nevada the first to hold a presidential
primary
we have reaction from new hampshire and
iowa plus seligman tom roberts says he
plans to run for
sheriff welcome back to politics now
i think the future is as many pundits
have said
that we'll become the first state to
have a primary
because iowa and new hampshire have not
been very
representative of what happens in the
country and that was former senator
harry reid the democrat talking to us
after last year's democratic caucus here
his push to have nevada be the first
state to vote on the presidential race
is moving forward the primaries the
nevada legislature passed a bill
at the session that makes the caucus a
primary in nevada and
leap frogs nevada to first in the
session of primaries now
in opposition to the bill republican
party chairman michael mcdonald released
this statement saying that
this measure is quote trying to play
chicken with primary dates
and that he says it's not a battle that
we will win now the states in front of
nevada
on the primary calendar caucus calendar
in one regard
is iowa and new hampshire here is a
response from new hampshire's
they've given every indication they
would fight this this is from the
democratic party chairman who says
we have successfully defended the
primary for decades and believe that we
have a strong argument
for new hampshire to retain its place at
the beginning of the queue
iowa's democratic party chairman says
it's working to ensure the state has a
crucial voice
in the nominating process as well david
charns so here's the statement by the
way from
the iowa chairman david charns spoke
with steve sibelius from the review
journal and i-8 news now
about the primary bill while they were
in carson city we're once again joined
here by 8 news now political analyst
steve sibelius also a politics
and government editor with the review
journal steve a lot happened
particularly in the late hours last
night going all the way up until that
midnight deadline but i want to talk
about
the bills that have the most effect for
most of us most of us watching at home
which is those election bills
yeah the during the pandemic for the
first time the majority of nevadans
voted by mail
they received the mail ballot by a
special action of the legislature well
they made that permanent so now
all active registered voters will
receive a ballot
in the mail unless you opt out and
choose say i want to go and vote in
person
and i don't want that mail ballot you
will get a ballot in the mail
a lot of people found it very convenient
it was it was
easy to to vote at home especially with
the long ballot that we had
when they tweeted it was like two pages
right with everybody right and back
right and and you know something that's
probably going to have national
implications
is going to have national implications
not a probable is this switch to
primaries
and possibly being the first now of
course iowa has the caucuses
new hampshire has primaries they set
their dates
this bill would make it the first
tuesday in february
could we actually be the first in the
nation primary we could
although new hampshire state law allows
the secretary of state of new hampshire
to set
their primary whenever he wants to to
make sure that it's first in the nation
so they could still leapfrog us
there's a lot of negotiations i think
that are going to have to be worked out
between the political parties as to who
actually goes first
whether we you know continue with the
iowa caucus first
but one thing is certain nevada's caucus
is a thing of the past there will be no
more caucuses you'll go to the polls
you'll vote for your choice for
president the way you vote in any other
election and that will happen once every
four years
so the governor now has 10 days to
decide what he's going to
sign because you know that's how
remember that uh i forget what it is the
let's have the make a bill song you know
the school of rock yeah so um he has to
sign this for for anything to become law
he can veto it it doesn't become law
or he can just let it become law on its
own anything you see that these folks
passed
that you think he's gonna automatically
veto we asked him last night and
he he wasn't so forthcoming yet yeah i
don't
see a lot of veto potential in the bills
that
he signed democratic house democratic
senate
sends bills over there i think they're
going to be pretty much aligned with
what the governor wants
and he has signaled i'm sure behind the
scenes what he would like to see what he
would not like to see
so i don't think there'll be a lot of
vetoes all right well we'll see what
happens in the next couple of days steve
thanks so much for your insight
three days here we've been on the ground
in carson city and we are in carson city
i'm david charns eight news now guys
back to you
as of the taping of this program so far
governor sysolak has not used a veto and
if he doesn't use one at all
it would be the first session since
governor kenny gwynne back in 2003
who also didn't use one at the time next
on politics now we're going to sort out
who's running for what in 2022
a look at the names lining up for clark
county sheriff and henderson mayor
welcome back henderson city councilwoman
michelle romero plans to run for mayor
current mayor debra march is term
limited in 2022
romero made the announcement on saturday
last saturday
this position is nonpartisan but romero
is a republican
she was just reelected in 2019 her city
council term ends in 2025
also looking ahead to the next session
here we've got assemblyman tom roberts
who tells politics now
he plans to run for sheriff i did
34 years in law enforcement i retired
to come up here and work in the
legislature i found that i
still miss law enforcement i like it
just like here i like serving my
community but i really believe that i
could make a difference
at metro if i went back and
there's an opportunity with the sheriff
running for governor and i think i'm
going to jump into the race and
i think the voters will be happy with
what they get my message
is look i want to do what's best for
the citizens of las vegas you know crime
i think is always in the back of
people's minds but also police the
delivery of police services is
i think we can do we do a good job at
metro i think we can always
do better i think we need to work with
the community close
to ensure that we're policing the way
they want to
and i think metro does a pretty good job
but i'd like to take it to the next step
so far roberts is the only candidate
who's declared the intention to run for
sheriff sheriff lombardo
is intending to run for governor
republican state legislatures across the
country have been trying to ban
something called critical race theory
from public schools
republican lawmakers are attempting to
ban what they
claim critical race theory teaches
students
proponents say learning about historical
injustices can be uncomfortable
that whites are an oppressor race and
other identity groups are oppressed i've
never heard an educator saying white
people are inherently
bad joining us now from washington is
alexander limon alex let's talk first
what exactly is
critical race theory critical race
theory is something that is not new
it's actually a concept that's been
around for decades i believe around 40
years or so
and some of the academic experts who
study it describe it as a theory where
you're
encouraged to take a critical lens to
examine u.s history
and the role that racism has played in
our country's history
and that role that it still continues to
play in
our laws in our society and how that
racism
is embedded in everyday life and so it
encourages people to use critical
thinking and again that critical lens
so that's the widely academic used
definition for it but
in recent months critical race theory
has had a big spotlight on it because
republican lawmakers both state-led
lawmakers and
also here on capitol hill have focused
in
on this issue claiming that it actually
teaches students to feel
guilty about being white that it teaches
students
that the white race is an
oppressor race and other races are the
victims and have been victimized and
they claim that it's a very
divisive theory that pits
races against each other and is divisive
for the country and so republican
lawmakers and state legislatures around
the country
like in oklahoma for example have either
already or are in the process
of trying to ban it from being taught in
public schools
well how frequently is this taught in
schools
funny you should ask because it's not
you know many school districts around
the country have been
kind of put in the spotlight and accused
of teaching critical race theory and
what all of these school districts have
said is that they do not actually teach
it this is not a theory
that is used in public k through 12
schools
it is mostly a theory that is used in
academic
higher learning circles you know in
colleges universities people getting
their phds for example in in
areas that are related related to race
and policy
that was alex limon from washington
you're watching
politics now
looking ahead boulder city has a
municipal election coming up june 15th
and early voting is already underway
down there runs till june 11th
there's an open city council seat and
two ballot initiatives
the first is to see if people want to
spend seven million dollars on a new
swimming pool
the second is whether or not the city
should sell land to fund that project
we have information on this for you at
8newsnow.com
we thank you for watching politics now
we'll see you right back here next week
you